[Applause]
thank you very much can I welcome
everyone here today and thank Port Vale
for having us here for the launch of
Labor's mission on crime
every one of us should be able to feel
safe on our streets in our town centers
and in our homes
and when things go wrong we need to know
that the police and criminal justice
system will be there for us
but too often after 13 years of
conservative government
and for too many people that just
doesn't happen
we don't see police on the beat too few
crimes are investigated or solved far
fewer criminals are being caught or
prosecuted under the conservatives
serious violence has gone up
and confidence in policing Has Fallen
and too often people feel that when they
need help no one comes and nothing is
done
and last week I talked to a woman who
said she no longer goes shopping in a
town center doesn't like her kids going
into town because she doesn't feel safe
because of anti-social behavior and she
doesn't see police Patrols in town
anymore and I've heard the same thing
too often heard from parents who were
worried about their kids because of
knife crime or youth violence in their
area and from people who are worried
that their elderly parents are being
targeted by scams or for young women
sick and tired of having to worry about
walking home from the bus stop on their
own or about abusive relationships at
the same time we know the police are
overstretched often picking up the
pieces when other services fail
including Rising mental health crises
and still struggling with the legacy of
austerity and out-of-date technology so
neighborhood policing too often has been
decimated leaving people feeling
frustrated that just crimes just aren't
being investigated and it takes too long
even when cases do go to court with huge
long delays
and then this week we had the truly
devastating report on the Metropolitan
Police by Louise Casey
yes problems that are specific to the
Met
but also issues that are very serious
for other forces as well
and yet we got nothing from the
conservative Home Secretary this week
literally nothing
no new plan to rebuild confidence no
action to make sure that all forces
tackle standards raise standards and
Tackle discrimination or get the police
back on the beat or tackle violence
against women and girls just a shrug of
the shoulders
that failure to act is letting down our
communities and it is also undermining
the vital work the incredible work many
police officers are doing every day to
keep us safe
and most troubling of all it is a home
office that is just standing back as
kierstama said this week a hands-off
home office
that is letting us down and labor is
clear that we need urgent action
to restore confidence in a system that
feels broken including getting police
back on the beat tackling crime catching
criminals and working together with
urgent action to reduce the most serious
harms of all including life knife crime
and violence against women and girls
and we know that this is not just about
the home office
that's why Steve Reed is working on
plans to speed up the courts and
strengthen Community Justice why Emily
Thornbury is working to increase
prosecutions lead the fight in tackling
fraud while Lisa nandi is working with
councils on tackling anti-social
behavior in our town centers while Lucy
Powell setting out stronger measures on
online crime and abuse and Bridget
Phillipson and Rosanna Alan Khan have
set out plans to put mental health
professionals in school to work with
young people with Jess Phillips Sarah
Jones and many others working on action
on policing and domestic abuse and
drawing on the work of people like Kim
McGuinness and orthumbria police and
crime commissioner tackling domestic
abuse
because care is made clear to us this is
a mission for all of us
and I had my first security briefing
more than 25 years ago as a member of
the intelligence and security committee
and since then I've worked with
successive labor home secretaries in
government and challenged and
scrutinized successive conservative home
secretaries as well as police Chiefs and
other agencies from opposition and I've
campaigned on tackling violence against
women and girls for decades
but I have never seen the home office
more adrift
than the conservative home office is now
never seen it failing so badly showing
no leadership as people feel more
worried
and as confidence in the police and
criminal justice system has fallen
they are letting our communities down
and we need huge leadership to turn that
around
we need serious commitment to change
and that is what you get
from the leader of the labor party
is someone who has spent years really
fighting crime Prosecuting criminals and
terrorists supporting victims of crime
fighting for justice
and doing some of the toughest jobs
holding people to account
and that's why he is the right person to
lead the fight against Crime and for
justice for keeping people safe and for
restoring confidence in policing by
consent and in the rule of law it's why
he is the right person to lead Britain
please welcome Kirsten
foreign
thank you very much
thank you Yvette thank you all of you
it's all fantastic to see you all here
this morning and to be here in burslem
the mother town of the potteries where
yeah where the Spades first hit the
ground in the construction of the great
Trent and mersey Canal uh a fact which
of course gives its name to Port Vale
although for me if I'm honest this is
better known as the ground where Arsenal
came really close to losing the double
in 1998. this is this is true
two drawers in the cup and a penalty
shootout very close penalty shootout
somewhere just over there I went out to
have a look at the pitch this morning to
look at where those penalties were taken
from
um but today we are here on more serious
business as Yvette said the launch of
Labor's Second National mission to make
our streets safe and stop criminals
getting away without punishment
no
now if you think that sounds basic
something which should be guaranteed in
a country like ours
then let me tell you you're right
nothing is more important more
fundamental to a democracy like ours the
rule of law is the foundation for
everything
Margaret Thatcher called it the first
duty of government and she was right
about that an expression of individual
liberty our rights and responsibilities
but also Justice fairness equality
one rule for all
that's the principle I've been proud to
serve all my adult life
as a human rights liar fighting for
families with young children trying to
escape mold infested accommodation
or for freedom of speech in the most
libel case
with the Police Service of Northern
Ireland advising them how to bring
communities together to make the Good
Friday agreement work
and at the crown prosecution Service as
the Director of public prosecutions
the same process principle
everyone protected everyone respected no
one denied the law no one above the law
not the murderers of Stephen Lawrence
who for a Time thought that they were
not Al-Qaeda terrorists
not MPS labor or conservatives gaming
the expensive system to line their
pockets I prosecuted them all and I'm
proud of that one rule for all
and that's what I found the pandemic
parties in Downing Street under Boris
Johnson so reprehensible
the circus of the last few days
a reminder if it's total disrespect for
a national sacrifice
that's why I said I'd resign if I'd
broken those same rules
I just couldn't have looked the British
people in the eye and asked them for
their trust
those values are too important to me
the core of my politics today
so if the Tories want to attack me for
being a human rights lawyer attack the
values I've stood up for my whole life
I say fine
that only shows how far they have fallen
and how little they understand working
people
because whatever the crime anti-social
Behavior hate crime serious violence
it's always working people who pay the
heaviest price working-class communities
who have to live under its shadow
that's why tackling crime Law and Order
will always be important for my labor
party fighting crime is a labor cause
I grew up working class in a small town
I know how important it is to feel safe
in your community
if you don't have a big house and a
garden the streets are where your kids
play
your community is your family your
neighbors your eyes and ears you have to
feel a sense of trust of confidence of
security
it's what gives you roots
a precondition of Hope
The Firm ground you can build your
aspirations up
but as somebody who's worked in criminal
justice for most of my life I also know
that far too often the inequalities that
still scar our society
class race gender do find an expression
in the very system that is supposed to
protect us all without discrimination
I've talked about this before but
the case that crystallized so much for
me
was the murder of a nurse called Jane
Clough
stabbed to death in the car park of the
Blackpool hospital where she worked
killed by the man awaiting trial or
multiple charges of raping her on the
one morning she went to work
unaccompanied
I will never forget the day her parents
John and Penny came to my office and
talked me through the awful treatment
they'd received from our criminal
justice system
it's a moment that has shaped everything
I've done since
everything I think about Justice
how incomprehensible pain can only be
met with practical action that if you
have the power and can do something for
the powerless you've got to roll up your
sleeves work night and day to make the
changes big and small which can if not
put things right
then at least protect the future
that's what happened that day
as I listened to John and Penny tell me
Jane's story
I knew a great Injustice had been done
and I made a promise to work with them
and make sure no other family would
suffer the same fate
so together we changed the guidelines on
rape cases in court
and crucially we forced a change in the
law that gave prosecutors the right to
appeal against a bail decision changes
which do give Extra Protection to women
brave enough like Jane
to place their faith in the system and
press charges
but it isn't enough
I know that in fact it's why I decided
to come into politics
because the more and more Case Files I
read
the more and more I could see those ugly
in inequalities at work
you saw it in grooming scandals like
Rochdale as well
how good prosecutors and decent police
officers people who hated crime
would end up looking for the perfect
victim
casting aspersions based on a way of
thinking that was out of date
out of touch with the experience of
victims and communities that they needed
to serve
why didn't you go to the police straight
away
why did you go back to them why did you
put up a fight
questions and assumptions that are
deeply flawed and have left vulnerable
people working class women and girls
especially
ignored voiceless
denied Justice
that's why the mission today matters to
me
I'm proud of my previous work proud of
my record at the crown prosecution
service but this is personal yes it's
Labor's plan to tackle the crime wave
gnawing away at our Collective sense of
security of course it is
but it's also unfinished business in my
life's work to deliver Justice for
working people
Justice which I'm sorry to say feels
quite absent as I look around Britain
now
the statistics spell it out serious
violence Rising again crime way too high
the charge rate
just five percent never lower a recipe
for impunity an invitation for criminals
to do whatever they want swanning around
our communities without consequence
and it doesn't stop there
our courts are backlogged victims
trapped in a Purgatory waiting for the
justice that they deserve
anti-social behavior is a growing blight
knife crime back on the rise and not
just in the inner cities as you know
it's increased in places like here in
the potteries as well
and then there's the crime
that Jane Clough faced that women face
domestic violence still Rife sexual
offenses higher than ever
do you know today
300 women in Britain will be raped
but of those 300 grapes
just three cases will see someone
charged
do you know I got my team to check those
figures because I couldn't believe them
but this is Britain right now
yet from the government silence
no urgency no reform no big agenda
nothing
I could say it's the usual Tory sticking
past the politics and it is
but this is complacency on another level
it's like they can't see the Britain
that they've created
maybe that's it
their kids don't go to the same schools
nobody fly tips on their streets the
threat of violence doesn't stalk their
communities they don't see the problems
and so they're complacent about the need
for solution
asking outdated questions making flawed
assumptions about victims policing crime
about everything
out of touch with the realities of
modern Britain
they should try and walk in your shoes
for a day or two
come speak to the teenage girls here at
the college in Stoke-on-Trent who told
me they're afraid to walk down their
High Street in broad daylight because
they know they'll get harassed
or the women's Refuge I visited in
Birmingham
and see the bruises not just on the arms
and bodies but in The Souls of the women
I met there
the family that wrote To Me hiding
terrified that their father will come
back to hurt them again waiting since
2018 for their day in court this is the
Britain they've created and they should
look it in the eye
working people don't feel safe I won't
take lectures from them on this I won't
have our commitment to Justice called
into question and I won't stop until
working people feel protected
this is our mission labor will make
Britain's streets safe
and we will do so as with all our
missions by bringing people together
with purpose and intent by embracing the
challenge that comes with clear
accountability and setting out four
clear measurable goals
one
as I announced on Tuesday
we will restore confidence in every
police force to its highest ever level
two we will halve incidents of knife
crime
free we will reverse the collapse in the
proportion of crime sold
and four by solving more crime by
reducing the number of victims who drop
out of the system
we will halve the levels of violence
against women and girls
none of this will be easy clearly as
I've always said Amazon should invite a
sharp intake of breath
but after this week nobody can doubt the
scale of our ambition nor its urgency
or for that matter how comprehensively
the toys have thrown in the towel
but equally it's obvious that these
targets require Partnerships not just
across government but between politics
and people
it's not just about the police and
criminal justice systems it's about
education Media Health Community
Services online regulation
tackling tackling the evils our young
boys are exposed to that follow them in
their pockets everywhere that they go
so yes change has to come from all of us
it is going to be a long hard Road
but there are some steps we need to take
together now
urgent priorities that my labor
government would respond to immediately
so let me take each of our targets one
by one starting as I did on Tuesday with
confidence in the police
because the horror of what we've seen
reported about the Metropolitan Police
this week cannot be understated
I know there are good officers in the
Met as of course there are across the
whole country
but the actions of that Force
collectively and individually have
tarnished the reputation of policing
everywhere
our policing by consent model
a precious model
is now hanging by a thread
and look the confidence levels in police
across the country are on a downward
Trend as well
nearly every person I meet has at least
one story an interaction with the police
where something wasn't followed up
calls unanswered opportunities to share
evidence missed
and so people give up
they stop bothering
crime becomes decriminalized
now
as Louise Casey pointed out austerity
has had a pernicious effect
I ran the crown prosecution service in
the early days of austerity I had a
front row seat for the chaos the lack of
planning and vision which came with the
cuts and I accept like every Public
Service the police have been failed by
this government
but you almost must have a plan you've
got to find a way to modernize got to
keep up with the way crime is changing
retain a visible presence on our streets
and there can never be any defense for
the institutional failings the racism
misogyny and homophobia that we've seen
in the men
that's why our mission will focus on
confidence it will push us to do the
hard yards to tackle The Wider sense of
impunity in society
unblock our courts and lower crime
meaningfully without perverse incentives
on charge or prosecution rates
confidence is everything
it's what effective visible open-minding
policing can provide for the communities
that it serves
and as we've seen this week it's what
bad policing destroys
so let me be very clear the next Labor
government will modernize British
policing
we will raise standards overhaul
training modernize misconduct and
vetting procedures we will root our
institutional discrimination wherever we
find it
I've seen what is possible with the
Police Service of Northern Ireland I had
a hand in it
and that word service
that captures what needs to be done
policing must change must start thinking
of itself as a public service must stand
with communities not above them respect
their values
because
if we can get Catholics to serve in
Northern Ireland integrate nationalist
communities there into policing
then there can be no justification for
any special pleading from the Met in
London or any police force policing must
start to serve women and minorities no
more excuses
but look modernizing the police is also
the first step we need to take on
halving violence against women and girls
you can't defeat misogyny without robust
policing but you can't have robust
policing without defeating misogyny
that's what modern policing looks like
what's serving your community looks like
so we'll put specialist domestic abuse
workers in the control rooms of every
police force responding to 999 calls
supporting victims of abuse we'll get a
specialist rape unit in every police
force and we'll also set up dedicated
rape courts
the current prosecution rates are a
disgrace
we all know how hard it is for women to
come forward
the criminal justice system only ever
sees the tip of the iceberg on sexual
violence
and that the experience of going to
court the way victims are treated
this doesn't work
I've been pushing for action on this for
nearly 10 years
in 2014 I spent nine months with Dory
Lawrence taking evidence and testimony
from victims
in 2016 I wrote a private member's
victims bill which had cross-party
support
the only reason it's not on the statute
book is that we don't have a government
capable of looking this problem in the
eye
but mark my words a labor government is
coming and we will bring forward a
proper victim's law
and something else that Louise Casey
made Crystal Clear is crucial to
restoring confidence
visible neighborhood policing
foreign
to get more police on the beat fighting
the virus that is anti-social Behavior
fly tipping off-road biking in rural
areas drugs now some people call this
low level I do not want to hear those
words
there's a family in my constituency
every night cannabis smoke Creeps in
from the street downstairs
into their children's bedroom
age four and six
that's not low level it's ruining their
lives
so we won't pull any punches on this
everyone protected everyone respected
that's what Justice Means
and the Tories are soft on it soft on
anti-social Behavior soft on the crime
that the most affects working-class
communities only labor will protect them
we'll get 13 000 extra police on our
streets bringing new respect orders
anti-social Behavior orders with teeth
and we'll get clever with fixed penalty
notices
if you want to commit vandalism or dump
your rubbish on our streets then you'd
be better be prepared to to clear up
your mess
because with labor in power that's
exactly what you'll be doing cleaner
streets are safer streets
but the reality of today's society as
any parent knows is that our children
need protecting in their homes as well
as on their streets
you can't fight behavior that is learned
online spread online glorified online
armed only with the tools of the past
take knife crime
we know so much of this is about
prevention
about pulling young boys back before
they get in too deep
it's about good Youth Work neighborhood
policing mental health support in every
school we'll do all that
it's about smart legislation as well
about making the criminal exploitation
of children illegal and using that to
Target the county line gangs who exploit
kids to do their dirty work
but it's also about standing up to the
big tech companies
seriously
how can we ignore the fact
a child can go onto the internet and buy
a machete as easily as a football
it's exactly the same thing with social
media algorithms that bombard young
minds with misogyny
both are social evils both an example of
where greed comes over good
so my message to the big tech companies
is this the Free Ride is over
if you make money from the sale of
weapons or the radicalization of people
online then we will find ways to make
you accountable you wouldn't get away
with it on the streets and you won't get
away with it online
thank you
but look the fight against online hate
shows the scale of the challenge that we
face
as I've said before about all our
missions
change must come from all of us success
depends on Unlocking The Pride and
purpose that's in every community
this is a new way of governing
but it can be done
from my experience in Northern Ireland
elsewhere I draw strength from the
unbelievable unbelievable campaigners
I've met
from my friends Doreen Lawrence the
cluffs being a smallman and more
I draw inspiration
and from the people of this country
communities like this I draw belief
change can happen and it can happen
quickly
people forget
it was only in the 1980s when the
physical punishment of children in
schools was banned and a huge cultural
changes followed
so why can't we imagine a society where
violence against women is stamped out
everywhere
why can't future citizens of our country
look back at this generation as the one
which turned the page on misogyny which
protected our children and made our
streets safe
I promise you this if we pull together
we can do this and I will give it
everything because this Mission crime
and Justice is my life's work
I've made it central to my labor party
because it's Central to the lives of
working people
for the confidence they need in their
Community to push on and hope for a
better future the foundation for a
better Britain where working people
succeed aspiration is rewarded children
are protected and crime is punished a
Britain where families once again feel
safe on their streets the basis for a
country that gets its hope its future
and its confidence back thank you very
much
thank you very much thank you
thank you very much
thank you
thank you all very much thank you we're
now going to take some questions from
the media and I've got a list of
um those that are here I hope
um starting with Liz from Skye Liz hello
yes thank you very much
um the first thing I would like to ask
you about is your tax return we saw the
prime ministers yesterday when are we
going to see yours are you going to
publish a summary are you going to
publish it in full and what do you make
of him paying an effective rate of 22 is
that reasonable or does that mean the
system should be overhauled and very
quickly if you don't mind just a short
one
um Sue gray if she is found to have
broken the civil service code because of
conversations that she had with you are
you still going to hire her uh thank you
very much let me deal with
um the question of my tax returns now
the prime minister's publishes I'll
published mine I hope to be able to do
that later on today so that's very very
straightforward
um I'm glad the Prime Minister has
published his tax returns
um I think that's the right thing to do
others will obviously analyze those
returns
um but I do think there's a wider point
about choices here and I'd say this
before or after he published his tax
returns which is the choices they make
on tax and the tax system are obvious
they always go after working people you
know if you look at the last 12 months
18 months in particular they always go
after working people so
in relation to sue gray I don't have the
Shadow of Doubt that she's acted
properly and everything that she has
done thank you very much Liz I think we
go next to Charlotte at LBC
and
I know you've spoke about police
recruitment before and but we've seen
police federations in the metropolitan
police commissioner Sir Mark Rowley warn
about staff retention and yes staff are
being recruited but they're
inexperienced and training is difficult
without funding and adequate resources
would you give the police a pay rise and
can you talk some more about how you
would halve incidents of knife crime
we've seen in northern England as well a
recent Spate of fatal knife incidents
involving teenagers would you put police
officers on the school gates to tackle
this and and also in your role as the
leader of the labor party was it
essential for you for work purposes to
have a drink with your staff and thank
them to boost morale during lockdown
uh uh
thank you um
we are breaking the habit of one
question per uh
not just two but three in there just
look on the question of I mean retention
is a very serious issue um and uh has to
be taken seriously it's why what Louise
Casey said was so important and I was
very struck by the fact that quite a lot
of the evidence that she collected was
actually from police officers themselves
a cry if you like from them for the
change that they need and obviously you
know whatever we do in relation to
public sector pay will be fully costed
and set out before we go into the
election but what I would say on that
and I think Louise Casey made this point
is if you look at some of the examples
that are listed of the behavior that she
criticizes in the report I think you'd
be very hard-pressed to say that's got
to do with pay
that's to do with culture Behavior
attitudes and Leadership
um and for my part far too often with
reports like this we try to find as it
were a quick and easy answer without
doing the hard yards of the change
that's desperately needed that will take
leadership it will require an iron will
so far as fatal my incidents are
concerned obviously this is Central to
our mission knife crime is pernicious
knife crime causes awful impacts on
victims and their families and it causes
young people to feel unsafe in their own
streets whether or not they're actually
subject to an incident of knife crime so
this is at the heart of Youth safety I
do think more work needs to be done in
around schools I do think more neat work
needs to be done on our streets that's
why our commitment to 13
000 more officers actually in our
communities working on a neighborhood
basis is so so important and also why
our commitment to tackle the acquisition
of knives online is so important it
should not be possible for a young
person to get a knife as easily they get
the football online in relation to I
mean I'm not going to comment overly on
uh the evidence that the former prime
minister gave yesterday there have been
plenty of commentary already but all I
can say is we did not have leaving
parties and the committee must now be
left to decide for itself what it makes
of the evidence that he has given them
thank you very much uh Sophie from the
mirror
um hi so my questions on crime
prevention in 2021 six children were
stabbed to death in Croydon all of the
perpetrators and victims involved have
been excluded from school of the prison
population 42 were expelled or
permanently excluded from school if
labor is serious about tackling the
causes of crime will you commit to
Banning School exclusions except for the
most extreme circumstances well Sophie
thank you for raising this because
um I've obviously been looking at this
for a very very long time and if you
look at the likelihood of a young person
ending up in prison
um then the indicators that are the most
significant are difficulties at primary
school and excluded at secondary school
and that's why it's very important that
if we're going to be tough on crime and
tough on the causes of crime you've
heard that before and you'll hear it
again because it's Central to everything
that is the labor party
by the way that's not me just picking up
on a phrase that we've used before tough
on crime tough on the cause of crime has
been something I've been living for
decades in my own personal and
professional life but if you're going to
do that you have to put your prevention
into your schools on the question of
exclusion I think that is an important
consideration but what I focused on
today which I do think is vitally
important is mental health support in
each of our schools there are you know
young people
who clearly need support in our schools
mental health support and they're not
getting it and I think that needs to be
in every school so thank you very much
for that Sophie I've got Richard
um please from The Stoke Sentinel
bitchin
and he he caused a bit of in for me not
so long ago describing
um people who fly tip carry out
anti-social behavior and do drugs and
Alleyways that kind of thing
um he described in the scumbag scrotes
um and such like
do you agree and linked to that there's
a feeling in this area that Boris
Johnson's kind of personal appeal
um is something that won uh the three
Tory members of parliament in so content
their seats at the last election and
does your personal appeal
um you know carry through with voters in
the same way
um and do you feel that that you know
will it will you be relying on um you
know kind of Voters
um not being as enamored with British
Union perhaps as they were with Boris
Johnson in order to win those seats well
Look in relation to the second part of
your question there's a very quick way
to find out
uh
we could have a general election
we've got very good candidates including
around here to replace some of those
candidates some MPS to there
on your point about
um anti-social Behavior and the
um comments of Jonathan firstly
um yeah anti-social behavior is really
serious and fly tipping is really
serious
um but I don't think I mean I wouldn't
use language like that I don't think
that's uh appropriate language to use
but also more deeply I think he's just
wrong to use language and not action I
think anybody in this can anybody in
this constitution
foreign
stop using language which is
disrespectful and just trying to gain
attention and do something about it
um
and that's why what we announced today
is so important in relation to effective
action
and sanctions with teeth that means that
you know if you fly to under a labor
government you'll be clearing it up and
that's what should be happening and you
know I'm afraid after 13 years to hear
Tori MPS going around saying things are
pretty awful around here it's a bit Rich
if they've just come down from the Moon
and say what's going on you've been in
power for 13 years that's what's going
on uh thank you Richard Chloe at the eye
Chloe thank you you said that you don't
think it's the right time to disband the
met but are there any circumstances in
which you could see yourself overhauling
the structure of the force and just on
violence against women what would you do
to actually tackle the culture behind
the violence sexual crimes
um
on on the
structures uh
um on the um structure
I I think this is about behavioral
change cultural change and about
leadership
and I say that because I worked at
Northern Ireland for five years with the
Police Service of Northern Ireland who
were transforming for the Royal Ulster
constabury I could see that yes you
could change personnel and structures
but what you needed to change most of
all was behaviors culture and that's
much much much more difficult I think
that something on the scale of what
happened in Northern Ireland with the
Police Service of Northern is now what's
needed in the mat I resist the sort of
structural break it up heads must role
model because I've seen that too often
before where when something goes wrong
there's a sort of tendency to say well
as long as one person goes then the
problem is solved I don't I've never
really believe that that actually solves
the problem and having looked at uh
Louise cases findings I don't think that
will be enough in relation to the met so
actually it's not that structure is you
know the ultimate change I actually
think the ultimate change is the
behavioral cultural change and I think
that's much much harder I want to back
the commissioner in the action he's
taking but I want him to go further and
he knows that we want him to go further
thank you Chloe
um Tom please from GB news
thank you uh the prime minister's tax
returns date back to all of his time in
cabinet will you be publishing your tax
returns for all of your time in Shadow
cabinet and just on today's
announcements you're pledging more
police more resources and very tough
targets how are you going to fund all of
this might it include raising capital
gains tax yes or no uh Tom um on the I
mean my I'll probably hopefully publish
my accounts later on today so you'll see
them in um due course
um in relation to the funding within the
police firstly let me deal with the
funding that we've already
um allocated which is the 13 000 new
officers we've set out that that will
come from
um the waste frankly that is there in
the resourcing and procurement across
the various forces
um and so there are all sorts of
inefficiencies I saw these for myself
Yvette Coopers analyzed them so we can
fund that from within but there are
other funding commitments that we've
already made in relation to the non-dom
status in relation to the vat exemption
for schools so wherever we've made a
commitment we've set out in terms how we
would pay for it and that's the way we
will continue to do this I just want to
add one thing Tom because it is really
important and that is that yes funding
and money is always important when it
comes to any public service including
the police
but reform is also important
um and I saw this when I was running you
know the prosecution service we needed
to reform
um I've already said it about the
National Health Service again you could
say the National Health Service needs of
all money but again with every public
service you can put more money in the
top but if you really want to challenge
change the outputs then it's reform as
well and that's why what I've said today
is a lot about the reform of police and
confidence in policing as well as the
money element thank you very much Tom
Jack from the Sun ciao thank you Zakia
we've learned today that dangerous
foreign criminals went on to commit even
more awful crimes after you campaign to
stop them being deported just three
years ago do you now regret that and
would you like to say sorry to their
victims Well Jack look what I'd say is
this
um that I think most people are fed up
to the back teeth with the government
that is seeking to blame everybody else
but themselves for the problems in
relation to crime
thank you
if there's a problem with confidence in
policing and there is then ask ourselves
who broke it if there's a problem with
that criminal justice system and there
is then ask yourself who broke it if
there's a problem with our Asylum and
deportation system then ask yourself who
broken frankly for a government 13 years
into power to cast around to blame
people anybody else but themselves for
what's going on shows her just how
desperate they are I'm afraid it's
casting around you can't blame the
opposition for the government's failures
I'm sorry about that but it is a rule in
politics
Amy from the telegraph Amy thank you
thank you just another question on tax
if I may so someone some of your MPS
have
unfair uh would you consider taxing
wealth at the same rate as income
um and then secondly how would you
respond to claims that your pension
arrangements are hypocritical and how
would you defend holding a pension pot
that is exempt from the lifetime
tax-free cap you are seeking to impose
on others
um look Amy in relation to tax obviously
we'll set out our position as we go into
an election I think others will analyze
the prime minister's Financial details
they're there for all to see in the end
that goes back to the point I made about
the choices that are made when this
government has had to raise taxes it's
always gone for the same people which is
working people and I think that's now
writ large in relation to what we've
seen in the last 24 hours in relation to
the my pensions scheme I mean let me
just take that um head on if I may
firstly
it was a government pension scheme put
in place for dpps so that's why it was a
stature instrument it's a government-run
scheme I'm absolutely committed to
changing
um what the government did last week
which was to give a tax cut to the
wealthiest one percent
now uh by the way we're also committed
to reversing non-doms
I don't intend that to exclude me
um and therefore
therefore I haven't uh taken um
advantage of this there are no tax
advantage nor do I want one so when we
reverse that um change the government
put in place last week I will be
included within that whatever change is
needed within legislation or anything
else I'm a very happy want to be and
will be in the same position as
everybody else in this country so I'd be
very very clear about that
thank you
Michael from the express
Michael thank you secure on attitudes
within the crown prosecution service do
you think prosecutors are willing to
take on enough cases do you think they
should be trying to prosecute more
rapists
um look I know how hard prosecutors work
and the police work and this is
difficult work I do want to see the
charge rate go up in relation to
prosecutions for violence against women
and girls
um I was shocked I think everybody
should be shocked to learn that the
charge rate for reported rapes
is 1.6 percent
over 98 don't go to court 98 of rapists
don't go to court
reported cases so do I want to drive
that up but I do absolutely bet I do and
that's why I've got brilliant people on
my front bench and Shadow cabinet will
work with me in government to make sure
we drive that rate up it cannot be right
that over 98 of rapists I'd never put
before a court
and I don't care what else the
government says that is a shameful
record and they should be rolling up
their sleeves and doing something about
it instead of casting around as they
always do saying it's somebody else's
fault everything is okay
um yes so yes the answer is we will
drive that rate up it is Central to what
we want to do which is to halve the
incidence of violence against women and
girls thank you so much for raising that
thank you
uh Jess
hi there um
okay if you if someone you loved was
assaulted in London would you feel
confident that when they reported it to
the Metropolitan Police that they would
get the best possible recourse to
Justice because Luis Casey says no and I
wonder if you agree with her and
secondly
um there's some news out today about the
College of policing and their advice on
charging
um that potentially those who were
charged or arrested shouldn't be named
or it should be optional for police
forces to name them
um
obviously with the case of David Carrick
the naming of him was one of the things
that prompted a lot of victims to come
forward so do you have concerns about
that well look Jess nobody reading the
Casey report
would be other than concerned about what
is illuminated in her report
but I do get asked this question would I
advise
my friends in due course they're a bit
younger my children to go to the
Metropolitan Police if something
happened to them
and the answer that is yes I would I
absolutely would and I think it's very
important that I say that there are very
good offices in the met and I would want
my children and my friends to have the
confidence to go forward and report and
I say that without any ambiguity
um at all on the separate issue of
naming those
to the charge the answer is it's
complicated uh and I don't I know and I
don't shy away from this there are very
good reasons why you shouldn't in a
number of cases and that's the norm
but there are too many examples where
um a perpetrator has not faced Justice
or faced full Justice because
um there hasn't been any naming and
we've seen in a number of cases where
once it's clear an individual has been
identified other people come forward
it's got to be a judgment call it is
very difficult you can almost bet that
whatever the Judgment call is people
will criticize it but I'm afraid I don't
agree with the blanket rule either way I
do think there's got to be flexibility
and I think if we don't have that we
will actually have a system that doesn't
work as well as it could thank you Jess
I've got Ryan from the mail
thank you very much um just to follow up
on the question from my colleague at the
sun
um you say today you want to stop
criminals getting away without
punishment but how can people take you
seriously with what with your history of
having
a campaign to prevent dangerous
criminals from being deported who then
go on to commit further offenses violent
offenses and secondly could I just ask
please
um are you still committed to updating
the gender recognition act to allow
self-identification for Trans people
thank you Ryan how can anybody look
people can have confidence in me taking
crime seriously
and Prosecuting and convicting criminals
because I did it for a living for five
years I headed up the crown prosecution
service seven thousand staff across
England and Wales with 100 offices
Prosecuting the best part of a million
cases year on year on year on Year and
that included rape and counter-terrorism
people smuggling drugs you name it along
with some of the issues like anti-social
Behavior theft and burglary as well so
Ryan I say and that's why I said in my
speech I'm proud of my record I devoted
five years of my life to Prosecuting
criminals I worked with the Police
Service in Northern Ireland not directly
Prosecuting criminals but to ensure that
they had the confidence of their
communities that they could fight crime
as well so there's a decade of work
countless rapists were prosecuted under
my watch Countess terrorists were
prosecuted under my watch so I stand on
my record I stand proudly on my record
Ryan the the second part of your
question was I'm sorry I've just
oh uh yeah look I mean I think that
um if we reflect on what's happened in
Scotland
um the lesson I take from that is that
um if you're going to make reforms you
have to carry the public with you and I
think that's a very important uh message
and I think that's why it's clear that
in Scotland there should be a reset of
the situation thank you and Richard from
PA
Richard
aye secure thank you very much
um it's a it's a broad strategy you've
set out I just wonder about those other
Frontline Services who often find
themselves in a thankless position
Probation Services social services and
acute mental health Mental Health
Community Services we've got a shocking
lack of Critical Care Mental Health beds
out there
um will there be more resources for
those people who often find themselves
criticized in the reports after cases
like Arthur labino hughes's death but
with nothing further done no more money
uh difficulty in retaining good staff
and all the problems that go with it
what will labor do about that if they
were in government yeah Richard thank
you for raising that because it's a
really important point one of my
frustrations when I was running at the
prosecution service within criminal
justice was that it felt like it was in
a silo separate from social services
from education from mental health from
Health when you know in Truth for very
many cases that I saw there was always
an opportunity where action could have
been taken in other departments that
supported or helped reduce crime so
Richard the first part of the answer is
that and I said it in my speech this has
to be something which is done across
different departments this cannot be
done in one place there is a mental
health a health a schooling an education
element to so many of the offenses that
come before our courts and end up in our
prisons we need to acknowledge that
that's why we want to be very tough on
um you know criminals getting caught
tough on criminals being charged tough
on criminals going to prison having
tough sentences but equally tough on the
work that needs to be done in our
communities in our schools in our
education in our mental health to
prevent and protect in the first place
now that isn't Richard all about budgets
and I'm not going to sell out budgets
now I'm obviously aware of the pressure
the risk down on all of those
departments it is a different way of
working and we need to break out of the
way that this has been operating for a
very long time now thank you Richard
thank you all very much indeed thank you
thank you